there's a video
of a woman who was arrested down on our
southern border
for human smuggling and you know what
goes on there is a study came out from
the huffington post fusion amnesty
international some years ago that said
that 60 to 80 of women and young girls
who are smuggled across the southern
border are sexually assaulted on the
journey a lot of them are put into
sexual servitude indentured servitude
prostitution and so one of these
these criminals one of these human
smugglers was arrested take a take a
listen
to her
reaction to the authorities
he's gonna pull the door and stay right
there before we move
hey
calm down
calm down calm down she's just growling
at them they're trying to close the door
she's growling like gollum and lord of
the rings like like a demon
[Music]
you've got these huge guys these huge
border patrol agents and they can't put
push this lady who's
channeling some sort of demon back into
the van
this is
the moral reality of evil okay this is a
reminder that evil is not just some
physical
some some metaphysical abstraction from
physical reality it's not just the way
that we talk about things in the
physical world you know and we just try
to use it as a symbol to make sense of
things no there's evil there's real evil
and sometimes people just talk like
demons and sometimes people do evil
things like smuggle little girls and
force them into prostitution and it's
just it's and it can't just be indulged
and it can't just be mollified and it
can't just be slightly kind of
rehabilitated evil has to be
repulsed it has to be rejected outright
you've got to acknowledge that
evil affects physical reality this is
why when you've got the precious and the
precious it contorts your body it may
this is why when people do drugs and
drugs and drugs they just start to look
bad you can see the physical effects of
this and we've got to say it's a
beautiful two-letter word that we seem
to have forgotten we've got to say
no if you're listening to this show some
of you probably
check out some things on the internet
that you don't want people to find out
about you know what i'm talking about
i'm talking about those websites that
maybe you know i'm talking about like
dailywire.com that can get you in a lot
of trouble now you're probably thinking
well why don't you just use incognito
mode let me tell you something incognito
mode does not hide your activity it
doesn't matter what mode you use or how
many times you clear your browsing
history to delete michael knowles show
delete
speechless at amazon delete no you can't
your internet service provider will
still see every single website you've
ever visited which is why even when i'm
at home i always use expressvpn on my
computer and on my phone i've got it
it's right there it's super easy to turn
on with the click of a button doesn't
matter who your isp is in the u.s
they can legally sell your information
to ad companies expressvpn is an app
that reroutes your internet connection
through their secure servers so your isp
cannot see the sites that you're
visiting protect your online activity
today with the number one rated vpn
that's number one rated by business
insider visit this exclusive link
expressvpn.com
[Music]
knowles you get an extra three months
for free on a one year package exp or
essvpn.com
knowles expressvpn.com knowles head on
over there to learn more did you like
that clip
i'm glad you like that i liked the clip
as well i liked that you liked it if you
want to get more of them subscribe get
notifications
right here ring that bell if you don't
get notifications because our friends at
youtube don't want you to for whatever
reason head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play wherever
you get your audio podcasts subscribe to
the michael knowles show leave a five
star review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]